tu sais tu qu'en réalité la terre est
plate comme une pizza et que la nasa
nous ment impunément complot
[Musique]
alors on a dit une terre plate avec
route au fromage et suppléments ananas
ça vous fera qu'à 2 54 milliards
d'années hop là merci up bonne journée
la terre serait elle aussi plate que ma
vie sentimentale c'est une théorie du
complot qui connaît un certain succès
ces dernières années grâce à une chose
magnifique internet tout commence ou
plutôt recommence comme on le verra
après au 19e siècle avec un petit
faquins d'anglais nommé samuel euros
boston il se faisait appelé parallax
avec un pseudo pareil ils avaient le
choix entre drop et une petite impro
freestyle sur l'instru trappe ou sortir
un bouquin complotistes il n'a pas
hésité longtemps selon lui notre planète
sur un disque centré sur le pôle nord
est bordée d'un haut mur de glace on
sait pas s'ils avaient des marcheurs
blanc au delà du mur par contre si vous
voulez mon avis ça manque un peu de
précision tous en tout cas ce qui est
rigolo c'est que son bouquin s'appelle
astronomie zététique la terre par un
globe quand on pense que ce qu'on
appelle zététique aujourd'hui c'est au
contraire l'étude rationnelle des
pseudosciences pour lutter contre les
complots et aiguiser l'esprit critique
avouez que c'est plutôt cocasse
d'ailleurs zététique vient du grec était
ticos qui elle cherchait rien à voir
avec la diététique un du grec et
diététiques hausse qui aime manger des
trucs dégueu mais bon pour la santé dans
la lignée de son bouquin parallaxe a
créé la première association de plates
east la société et éthiques notez
toujours l'ironie à laquelle succèdera
ensuite la société et éthique
universelle lancé par une dénommée lady
elisabeth blunt cette blonde ne chantait
pas sûrs beautiful mais elle a créé
cette société dans l'espoir de propager
les connaissances liées à la cosmogonie
naturel en confirmation d écriture
simple sur la base d'expériences
scientifiques pour elle la bible affirme
que la terre est plate et elle va
financer plein d'études scientifiques
pour essayer de le montrer spoiler bas a
pas trop réussi et donc c'est dans la
lignée de ces coquins de britanniques
qui est né en angleterre aussi la flat
earth society la société de la terre
plate elle est née en 1956 et elle sévit
encore aujourd'hui c'est l'association
officielle des partisans de la terre
plate qu'on appelle parfois les plates
east à l'opposé des globice tu ces
dernières années les activités de cette
association se concentre essentiellement
sur un forum en ligne c'est ce que vos
parents utilisaient pour discuter sur
internet avant les réseaux sociaux tous
les membres de la flat earth society
n'ont pas la même vision d'interprète en
mai globalement globe vous l'avez ils
s'accordent à dire qu'il ya un complot
mondial pour nous cacher la véritable
forme de la plaine les agences spatiales
nous mentent les fabricants de gps aussi
et toutes les images que vous voyez
passer de la terre depuis l'espace là
c'est du flan thomas pesquet démission
ce que je trouve marrant c'est que cette
théorie du complot a beau être super
actuelle en fait elle prend racine ya
plusieurs siècles bien avant nos facs un
d'anglais en fait c'est une fête nuke on
se trimballe depuis déjà dix générations
au moins aller hop je vous emmène au
moyen âge on pense souvent qu'à cette
époque tout le monde croyait vivre sur
une très large crêpes et même une crêpe
au sucre 1 d'après certaines sources
bretonne eh bien figurez-vous que pas du
tout en fait nos ancêtres savaient très
bien que la terre était ronde cette fête
news remonterait au xviie xviiie siècle
certaines personnes souhaitaient
ridiculiser les croyances du moyen-âge
pour mettre en avant le conflit entre
science et religion un truc du genre de
olala vous voyez la méchante église elle
fait tellement pression sur le monde
qu'elle impose sa vision d'une terre
plate malgré les preuves scientifiques
de sa rotondité eh oui c'est comme ça
que me dit un retour dit et voilà je
joue l'offre pour votre prochaine partie
de scrabble c'est complètement faux donc
nos ancêtres savaient très bien que la
terre était ronde c'était même un secret
pour personne depuis l'antiquité en fait
bon alors du temps des vieux grecque
elle un peu passés par toutes les formes
à notre pauvre planète elle a été tour à
tour un tambourin disque plat posé sur
l'eau et même un cylindre mais c'est
finalement un pote de pythagore qui
propose au vème siècle avant selena
gomez l'idée d'une terre sphérique comme
un ballon l'auteur de cette idée
s'appelait parmesan par minute par la
déformation professionnelle et bigot son
intuition était la bonne comme on a pu
le confirmer après avec plein
d'observation par exemple quand il ya
une éclipse de lune l'ombre que la terre
projette sur la lune est en forme d'arc
de cercle ce qui n'est possible qu'avec
une terre ce faire et puis il ya eu ce
cher eratosthène qui a non seulement
confirmé que la terre et espère hic mais
qui en plus a pu calculer son diamètre
grâce à un dromadaire un puits et un
obélisque mais c'est une autre histoire
pour en revenir à cette feuille caillou
sur le moyen âge pourquoi chercher ton à
faire croire qu'à l'époque la terre
était considérée plate comme une limande
et bien probablement parce que ça allait
bien dans le récit des siècles suivants
le savez au moyen âge on en connaît une
bonne couche 1 heureusement qu'on a eu
tous ces philosophes des lumières pour
nous éclairer un peu de leurs lanternes
et nous sortir de douze siècles
d'obscurantisme ce qui est tout aussi
faux en bien sûr ça aussi c'est une
vision coriace encore pas mal véhicule
est aujourd'hui mais ce sera pour une
autre fois et quelle meilleure façon de
ridiculiser les gens que les faire
passer pour des plates east
bref pour conclure la terre plate est
bel et bien une théorie du complot nées
d'une fête new vieille de plusieurs
siècles si vous pouviez remonter dans le
temps pour y et boire un thé avec votre
arrière arrière arrière grand mère et
lui dire à l'heure à la terre plate et
elle vous répondrais arts n'en parle pas
voilà ce sera une discussion vraiment
très intéressante
[Musique]
le tard place
oh
et
[Musique]